welcome back during the pandemic it was
easy to put on weight losing that weight
post pandemic is a little more difficult
dr nash in total transformation the
sponsors of this next segment they have
the solution
dr nash it is always great to have you
on the show how you doing today i'm
great how are you doing today i'm good
i'm gonna start with something you sent
me last week some weight loss stats that
just kind of blew my mind
data shows 61 of americans saw an
undesired weight change during the
pandemic of those over 42
saw weight gain and the average amount
of weight gain was 42 pounds and for
most of those people the weight is not
coming off now that the pandemic is
coming to an end
these stats this is depressing during
the lockdowns during the health crisis
while the topic of obesity and its
relations to symptom severity or outcome
with being obese that was mentioned what
was never really mentioned is just how
much weight we were gaining and nothing
was mentioned about the importance of
doing something to reduce or reverse it
so basically authorities just thought
the lockdown was going to be for two
weeks but as it continued the obesity
got worse and in fact the us is now at a
42.4
obesity rate it's the highest our
nation's ever seen
wow unbelievable so people put the
weight on during the pandemic but now
people our lives are back we're out and
about more active how come that weight
is not coming off for some people
one people's activity levels still
aren't back to their pre-pandemic days
we don't realize just how much activity
we took out we've also been conditioned
to eat even larger amounts of food and
even more food from processed fast food
or convenient sources
understandably so but the problem is
there's no focus now as we come out on
rebuilding the health and correcting the
damage and people that are still at high
risk are just continuing to stay away
from doctors and do the thing that's
driving the problem so you have an
example today uh to talk about about the
success of your program one of the
people that we're looking at today is
meredith and i specifically chose
meredith because she did my program
during the lockdowns and that meant that
there was nothing she could do the only
fancy thing she could do is walk so she
lost 35 pounds during the pandemic she
also was able to hold it eating two to
three thousand calories a day and when
you look at her body you can see it's a
complete transformation dr nash aren't
we seeing weight gain in people because
of more inactivity there's more than
just activity that drives a stubborn
weight problem so while tracking
calories are absolutely important in a
weight loss effort most people are
unaware of the chemical and the hormonal
signals they're getting from the food
that they eat that they eat so see these
signals not only drive a stubborn weight
problem but they drive damage like heart
disease diabetes fatty liver and
alzheimer's so if that damage that's
biological is not being corrected
most likely the weight loss is going to
be slow stubborn and temporary meaning
we're going to gain it back every week
you come on the show you bring a special
what do you have for us this week
so normally when i do the online
evaluation of course i have to determine
what's wrong
that requires a bit of work so it's 97
when people call my office but when i go
on las vegas now and get to talk to jc
we always want to do something great so
we have 10 spots available right now for
the online evaluation at only 9.97 the
spots go fast and you want to book them
online so check out the information
we're showing to secure your spot so
that i can help you
thank you again to total transformation
for sponsoring this segment las vegas
now we'll be right